So, World building is another kind of speculative
Futures approach this is an image from the movie
Minority Report which is set around the time frame
of 2050-ish and to build the world the filmmakers
had to research what 2050-ish could be like it
wasn't just about looking into the technologies
that could happen it was also about diving into
what political systems might be like what are the
ecological contexts what are the cultural norms
and the flood was so successful at grounding what
at the time were really Fringe areas of research
responsive targeted advertising or touch screen
tag like that wasn't around when it came out in
the early 2000s that it led to hundreds of patents
in the years since because we could really
see how these things might impact daily life
these days some speculative features are designed
to be experiential in digital form this example
is from bidibon for slate which is a VR
exploration of a climate change Toronto
by the First Nation artist Lisa Jackson so
as you put on these VR goggles you explore
what Toronto could be it's hotter it's wetter
and you also hear the languages of different
First Nation people the wendot the Ojibwe the
Mohawk as you're moving through this world so
you're connecting to different aspects of its past
it's present as you are also exploring its future
another approach is design fiction these are
typically ways of creating prototypes of tools
that occur in a given scenario what Sanders showed
us at the beginning is very much a design fiction
another example that I love is called ayapa
repository and it's a 2016 effort by two artists
ayodamolo acostende and salomeya Sega and
they made basically a museum and a resource
library of objects that affirm the futures of
black people so they got together with some
different community members they brainstormed
what some of these objects might be that can
support black life in coming years and then they
made them into objects so very much from like the
afrofuturism tradition of doing this work another
speculative Futures tactic is speculative design
which is basically a form for using design to
challenge assumptions about current conditions
and Convention this particular project is hyphen
lab's neurospeculative afrofeminism Salon which
re-envisions a black hair salon as a lab for neuro
cosmetology and cognitive enhancement so again
challenging the idea of what a black hair salon
can be and doing it in high resolution fashion
some speculative Futures use more simple
tactics this is a project by the artist
candy Chang she did a series after Hurricane
Katrina in New Orleans in the mid 2000s and
she covered buildings that had been made Vincent
and abandoned After the Storm occurred she covered
them with these stickers asking people to add
their ideas of what they wish those buildings
were instead and its Simplicity gets to the heart
of really what speculative Futures are all about
their means of asking what if and why not what
else can exist here in place of what is right now
so the process of proactively engaging
with the future and these personal high
resolution tactile ways is something that
researchers find increases are resilience
as individuals and as societies the more we
imagine what the future can be the stronger
our abilities to engage with longer time frames
become the more we do that the more we look into
longer time frames the more frequently we end up
challenging assumptions and current conventions
the more we challenge those assumptions
the more that our senses of autonomy and
resilience start to expand so doing this work
can make us more resilient on individual levels
the more we imagine the future together the
more socially resilient we often become social
resilience is essentially a different community's
ability to adapt cope deal with different kinds of
Social and environmental hazards and researchers
are finding that just as important as ecological
and infrastructural resiliences social resilience
is just as critical this picture is an image of
Chicago's 1995 Heatwave which killed hundreds
of people across the city and researchers have
found in the decades since that communities that
whether the event more safely where less people
died were those where people knew each other
they were socially resilient because they were
socially connected so while infrastructural
resilience for example can take large amounts
of time and money to achieve social resilience
are connections to each other the institutions
that hopefully support us is a more immediate
opportunity that still has very real impact
so researchers have found that stronger
degrees of collaboration and reciprocity are an
effective means of enhancing that aspect of social
resilience so collaboration is a way of deepening
trust and connection also lays the groundwork
for self-determination all of which can be very
critical to enhancing resilience so speculative
Futures tactics help us do this work help us
build these Connections in a few different ways
one is by cultivating possibility through play
so one example of what this can look
like is a project called the Republic
of Columbus being and it was an effort that
was led by an artist named Jorge Manos Rubio
while he was working in Columbus spring
which is a neighborhood in West Amsterdam
so residents in the area come from a lot of
different cultures which has resulted in some
conflict over the years and after trying some more
traditional measures to address these issues local
government asked different artists and designers
to try some more experimental tactics so Manos
Rubio worked with residents in the area to come up
with the idea of turning the local square into a
micronation so even though he was the one who
came up with this initial concept of creating
a micronation he used speculative Futures tools
to invite The Wider Community to inhabit it and
explore what it meant to create this alternative
reality in the moment so they use speculative
features tactics to invite different members of
the community into this process they made their
own money passport stamps design fictions they
created a National Space Agency they visited the
actual European space agency but they also came
back to Columbus being to the micronation of
Columbus Spain and used Tyvek kites to test out
what their own future rocket launches could be
they created their own Olympic sports teams so
as the months progressed the square became a
sanctioned micronation acknowledged in Amsterdam
but also by other micronations worldwide it was a
place where residents could start to imagine
that they were citizens of their own shared
nation state and live out the ramifications of
doing so in real time so this was a kind of play
this was an experimentation and it was also a way
of stepping again temporarily out of the conflict
Zone that was this present State between people
who had a lot of differences with each other and
it wasn't about ignoring the fact that those
differences existed it was about saying what
else can also exist here and then creating a space
to work through and have collaborative discussion
about what else that could be in creating trust
to different degrees in the process this is not
to say that this solved all of Columbus
beans issues because it did not but it was
again a way of cultivating new degrees of trust I
shared identity and a certain sense of belonging
so speculative Futures also invite us to not
just think about the future but to use our
senses in order to feel it and that can be a
way of making the future I feel like a really
personal place so this is a shot from a 2017
project called the Future Energy lab created
by the studio superflex for the government of the
United Arab Emirates superflex created a series
of interactive experiential Futures installations
with the goal of influencing the country's energy
policies so they identified five different energy
scenarios that could occur in the country up to
the year 2050 and they made an energy simulator
role-playing game different interactive objects
so that different decision makers the Prime
Minister was involved the head of cabinet they
could explore what these different Energy Futures
would be again by feeling into and exploring in
tactile ways with the ramifications could go down
as so in one scenario people got to smell the air
that might occur if current fossil fuel emissions
rates continued so it was a pretty noxious mix
of carbon monoxide nitrous oxide it smelled like
rotten eggs and it was an experience that allowed
people to not just think about air quality in the
future but to really feel it to experience it I'm
borrowing a phrase from Stuart candy who's a long
now fellow and a former colleague of mine that
speculative Futures this work helps us to not just
see into the future but feel into the future and
when we do so we can start to really relate to the
Future as a fundamentally personal place which it
really is we will be living some of us at least 30
years from now our children our grandchildren will
be living there the speculative features can also
be a powerful way of balancing between the parts
of our brain that work with long-term vision and
other parts that are more focused on the here and
now because speculative Futures tools really focus
on different narrative aspects that can be a way
of again linking the specific and the personal to
initiate the balance between these two time frames